Think about that. This is why ancient civilizations certain ones rejected the concept of money?
And this is how our system works today you have a finite amount of money, and you charge interest on it
So how is it possible if there's a finite amount?
For everyone to pay back all the debt in the world? Dude, I hate to break it to you, but it's not possible
Technically there's no way to pay off all the debt in the world.
No, so as soon as you take money with interest your shuzbut, but which is why it was illegal until the Renaissance.
What made it illegal? The feudal system. Greed.
We have a lot of Airsoft guns in the studio, My favorite one is this
M9 beretta, but the thing is it's broken. This is a this is a quality airsoft gun
Have you ever played a game with it? No.
It's just my favorite to look at like when we talk about stuff. It's it's like a fidget. Item. You know
Have you ever fixed and an Airsoft gun, Jake? I fix airsoft guns all the time.
How 'bout this. If I fix this,
I get one Steven's Buck from you.
A Steven's Buck? Yeah.
Yeah. I don't even think the people know what a Steven's Buck is.
There's this great place nearby where Nick and I eat lunch almost every day each lunch meal is one Steven's Buck and
Sometimes Nick and I trade Stevens bucks depending on, what day it is and who forgets whose wallet. A form of currency.
Yeah between him and I, it's form of currency. It's on the rise. I think we should actually print out some Steven's Bucks.
If I can fix this. All right if you can fix this I owe you a Steven's Buck. Here you go.
Steve, if you remember, came in last week and said.
We had to put in this handrail we had to do absolutely
And we have to get a big ol
Flammable liquid storage cabinet for all like our flammable stuff repaint aerosol to set that up so we have a delivery
This longer
Burnt down so I've been doing this for the last three years now. We could store all of our
spray paint
explosives
Fireworks her per the border of the great city of Los Angeles we am the good Steve and the great Steve
We are required to put this fire cabinet into our workshop. We think we found a place for it right here
No in here. We'll just put it right here
It's gonna be kind of awkward, but like it's the best spot for it
No, I mean in general that's pretty awkward because it cuts off
No one goes over there, and there's no room. Oh trust me. There's still be room yes
See everything I trust and do I gotta put up with applesauce
Well that's your problem right there boy, there's an airsoft BB in the in the hammer
Ready ready, I'm about to fix this
Done
By dolly real fire she'll fire look at
All the safety on is it
what but now you can now you can finish your movie scene where the person has the gun pointed at the bad guy at the
end
Hold on these should be stuck
lately look at those Stevens bucks, dude
There's a finite supply
Damn, how the feudal system just valued land
over
Cash there was a lot of reasons
But one of the reasons was the kings and queens didn't want people that controlled the money to have more power than they did oh
Yeah that you're right. How do we yeah? How do we control this you know I are you kidding
This is freaking beautiful. Just put everything you know what?
This morning for super cute
What would it cost weight plus delivery everything all in 370 book really. That's it yeah. That's a
$1,250 cabinet. What are you doing?
I am here to take photographs for the insurance company the fire insurance company because they
Requested when he inspected wishes that I put a handrail in even though
There's never been a handrail there in 35 years ever built one immediately, and they want me to they wanted me to put
Earthquake strapping on the water heater, which I did immediately
and they also said that people that have flammable materials have to have a
Real approved double metal fire, and you guys got one. It's unbelievable I
Got to take a photograph of this. This is just like beautiful man, man
Just you know we know what was weird was that I was showing I said hey look at this
This is really great these guys
these are all props or you know and
They make their own swords they make their own things. They shoot there are things they construct their own helmets, right?
Yeah, they they do all this neat stuff would they fabricate their own stuff
And we're sitting out in the back in the garden, and he goes
How do they fabricate those neat masks and I went I don't know foam cord they put it together paint he goes
Do you think those masks are flammable go? I don't know I've never lit one on fire
I never know what he goes because I'm gonna have to inspect what materials
they make the masks out of and if they do they're gonna need an approved fire cabinet, and I went
What it's how about this?
I mean so first of all is it the company that pays for the Stephens
No, no no the company doesn't have anything to do with this
We're talking to Stevens bucks if we lose one one of these little Stephens books
We have to buy a whole Stephen each each Stephen buck is worth 14 American dollars. It's true
In the money game information is everything and we can't let them know for every Stephens buck that I get from you is
An lunch at Stephens that you have to pay for
That is what a Stephens buck means give a buck to somebody that already owes you it's just representative of the debt
How do we in debt everybody when we have all the Bucks so if I get a Stephens buck from you?
That's you paying me a big lunch for me, and I get to use that Stephens bucket anytime
I guess I give you a Stephens back. Okay now. What happens when I go Stephens I?
Tell you I want to spend my Stephens buck, which means you have to pay for my lunch. Yes so anytime
I need another battery ace to have a man read so so anytime you need an IOU for Stephens lunch
Anytime you hold a Stephens book to have an IOU. Oh god. That's gonna get confusing so fast so currently
It's an economy
Okay
So the currents ain't no comic I Got News for you
The style of the entire reserve system is a calm alright usually a Stevens, but yes
So so so so wait, so I do owe you and when I give it to you yes
Okay now
Now when I go to Stevens I can say I want to spend my Stevens buck that Jake gave me
So jake has to pay my lunch. No one owes anyone anything, but you want a free lunch
I want a free lunch like somebody should write your name on the but in the previous thing with the with the gun
Mm-hmm since we bet on that and you lost
You'd give me a buck that I would then hold and tell my name
If it's a true currency the more bucks you have the better of a position
You're in I still think you should write names make it specific cuz it is a specific thing
It's not like that means I could you know what I think I think the only fair rule is after
so here look give me that book I
Write my name down on this IOU students there you go
You can cash it in whenever and then once I pay for your Stevens
You give it back, and I burn it they're worth nothing until I sign my name on it
And then it's worth everything and it's worth $14. No we're dramatic we don't hurt her we don't burn it though
We each have a unique seal or signature only that person can write it if your sigil is on a
Stevens buck and someone gives it to you. You're like look you go first
I was good so that way you don't have to be connected
necessarily to the debt that like if you and I made that debt so and you give it to me
Now I could make a dad like Bagwell. I have a Knick buck and I can give it to Carl
What's to say it's not gonna get recirculated unfairly if you don't get rid of it
Or destroy it because you have a good bank
Yeah, it has to go back to me, and yeah, I just want to confirm that yeah, but then you hold it you
Mean we could just make money with our residuals on it
Printing money print some money yeah
This is actually this is really interesting conversation because this is kind of how state currency used to work
Which is why we had to get off that system to do this to each other
Yeah, they do this to each other and be like well Virginia's got great money, but New Hampshire. I don't know about them
Yeah, you can design whatever bill you want. It's just known it has to have one
One common mark on it that establishes that as a Stephens budget
We should we have them all up uniform except for the faces and this
So we are literally making our own currency for free lunches or anything
We should make them besides of bills
Oh, let's make them the size of bills really and then if they're properly so that means they have to be six inches by was
It two and a half